Avanza en su plan para revolucionar
Twitter el recién asumido director de la
red social reveló el costo para la
verificación el actual sistema de
Twitter de nobles y Plebeyos que
determina quién tiene o no tiene
verificación es una estupidez poder para
el pueblo certificación por 8 dólares al
mes una suscripción para obtener
funciones adicionales En comparación con
los usuarios de la versión gratuita que
representan la mayoría el objetivo es
doble diversificar los ingresos de la
plataforma menos lucrativos que los de
otros gigantes digitales californianos y
tranquilizar a los anunciantes tras la
adquisición de la red social a finales
de octubre el empresario compró Twitter
por 44 mil millones de dólares alegando
que quería flexibilizar la moderación
para conseguir más democracia al
instante despidió a los ejecutivos lo
que preocupó a marcas como General
Motors que desde entonces ha retirado su
publicidad de la red pero también muchos
usuarios anunciaron que recurrirían a
los competidores de Twitter en caso de
cambios entre los más importantes están
mastodon Counter social e incluso
diáspora no hay nada que haga cambiar de
opinión al nuevo jefe de Twitter este
miércoles y los modos que persiste y
firma los que se quejan por favor sigan
quejándose pero les costará 8 dólares
escribió